laure alone qui vient en invité surprise
à cet enregistrement c'est vrai qu'elle
a affolé les vidéos dans des enfants de
choeur elle a battu tous les records
après une seule chronique
bravo il ya eu quelques petits remous
avec sa chronique l'actualité raconter
aux enfants le premier sujet était le
virus ebola et la tenue à être avec nous
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
pour jean-jacques bonjour à toute
l'équipe
donc il ya deux semaines j'ai fait ma
première chronique dans cette émission
et c'était super beaucoup de rires
beaucoup d'encouragements et puis
surtout beaucoup beaucoup de messages
sur facebook alors j'en ai sélectionné
quelques-uns parce que je voulais
partager ce bonheur avec vous donc voici
ma première critique
jonathan m laura j'ai écouté ta
chronique vat jeté dans la meuse espèce
de grosse kaunas alors kévin b va te
pendre sa mère la [ __ ]
jérôme 2 w avec ou sans l'aura je me
fais toujours chier dans cette émission
de merde on ma mère était tellement
fière de moi au par contre mon
producteur jeremy ferrari lui n'était
pas du tout content non il a dit comment
est ce possible que tu arrives à avoir
autant d' insulte sur un texte de quatre
minutes alors que moi j'ai besoin d'un
spectacle de trois heures pour en
arriver là mais cette chronique qui a
aussi été l'occasion d'avoir mon premier
article
alors c'est un article des femmes
prévoyantes socialistes
bon ya toujours des gens qui régnait
c'est vrai que mettre ensemble
prévoyante et socialistes c'est drôle
bon c'est vrai que quand on est
humoriste est comme ça une critique des
femmes prévoyantes socialistes c'est un
peu comme quand on est auteur d'essais
philosophiques et qu'on reçoit une
critique de franck ribéry on est
agréablement surpris est vraiment
curieux de voir ce que ça donne alors
voici comment les femmes prévoyantes
socialistes qualifie ma chronique quatre
minutes aux relents pestilentiels de
racisme et de sexisme et c'est là que je
me dis finalement va te jeter dans la
meuse kaunas eh bien on n'était pas si
mal que ça
alors ma chronique qui dénonçait sur un
ton sarcastique le fait que les
européens ne se sont inquiétés des
mollahs que quand le virus est arrivé
chez eux a suscité un tas de questions
chez les femmes prévoyantes dans celle
ci
cette émission pré suppose tels que ses
auditeurs comprenne son second degré et
là je me dis effectivement je suis allé
trop loin et je présente mes excuses à
tous les auditeurs
parce que à cause de moi vous vous êtes
fait prendre pour des imbéciles par les
femmes prévoyantes socialistes et ça
c'est vrai que c'est vraiment déplacé
mais ce n'est pas tout elle se demande
aussi pourquoi cody en verre qui j'ai
selon elle tenu des propos racistes
harry plutôt que de s'insurger serait ce
parce que cody est une personne
intelligente qui comprend le second
degré non les femmes prévoyantes ont une
toute autre explication que voici
cody pouvait-il choisir de ne pas rire
il est vrai que laura se dédouane de
toute affront envers lui en tenant des
propos flatteurs sur la taille de son
sexe donc si on en croit la journaliste
des femmes prévoyantes socialistes quand
un africain se sent insulté par des
propos racistes si on lui dit dans la
foulée qu'il a une belle grosse [ __ ]
ils oublient tout il est content et
rigole
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai on l'aura donc
personnellement je peux africain avec
moi ça marche
alors je pourrais bien entendu faire
remarquer à la personne qui a écrit
l'article que cette affirmation est
empreinte de roland pestilentielle de
racisme et de sexisme ou encore lui
signaler que le mot flatteur prend un s
au pluriel
je vous réussi de faire observer que
lorsqu'elle parle je cite des préjugés
les plus inscrit dans la population
belge blanche
c'est toute une population qu'elle
traite de raciste ou encore lui suggérer
que quand on écrit un article qui se
veut engagé et dénonciateur envers une
émission d'une grande chaîne publique
on a au moins les couilles de la signer
mais puisque cette personne a trouvé
judicieux de citer desproges
dans un texte qui encourage la censure
et ayant d'ailleurs une petite français
pour ce pauvre des proches qui doit être
en train de danser la macarena dans sa
tombe
eh bien je répondrai simplement à cette
personne en citant pierre desproges à
mon tour parfois il vaut mieux se taire
et passer pour un imbécile que de
l'ouvrir et ne laissait aucun doute là
dessus
[Applaudissements]
et j'en profiterai pour partager avec
cette personne ainsi qu'avec tous les
censeurs et autres adeptes du on peut
rire de tout mais quand même pas de ça
ce court extrait de la définition d'une
satire la caricature et le second degré
sont des techniques courantes de la
satire dans laquelle l'auteur exagère
une situation en disant le contraire de
ce qu'il pense
dans le but de la tournée en dérision et
de la dénoncer et j'ajouterai que
l'esprit c'est comme les parachutes ça
ne fonctionne que quand c'est ouvert
alors pour conclure je suis désolé de
décevoir les accros du scandale facile
mais non cette émission n'est pas
raciste
elle est juste parfois pas facile à
comprendre pour les cons mais cette fois
on ne pourra pas dire qu'on s'en prend à
une minorité
merci
[Applaudissements]